the test of the next conservative leader
as prime minister will come in places
like this cruz one of those so-called
red wall seats the tories turned blue in
2019 keeping hold of them is a different
matter altogether
such a consequential decision then
seemed to call for a grand setting we
brought together four of those
conservative members undecided at the
start of the evening to deliver their
judgment
for them which candidate was most in
touch with the needs of the north is a
decisive factor and that for them
appears to be liz trust
and we actually want leveling up to no
longer just be a term and actually be a
real thing and i think liz trust is
leaning towards more
honesty about actually i'm going to do x
y and z to make your life easier it is a
real difficult one here it is really
difficult and you know i suppose i am
swaying towards liz she
was educated in the north she's
much more in touch with what northern
voters hold dear than rishi i would
definitely be leaning to wisely trust
yeah definitely he does feel that the
more the tory grassroots sees and hears
of liz trust the more she consolidates
her lead a few more votes it seems are
in the bank here it was places like this
that put their trust in the
conservatives three years ago they're
edging closer now to deciding who they
trust to keep those promises greg milam
sky news crew